we wanted there to be tons of mutants
[Music]
there was this huge well of mutant
characters that were kind of under
utilized
[Music]
and we met with Ice Cube and we said
okay the character's name is Superfly
and he looks like this ice cube laughed
and smiled and we're like I think
cool super villain I'm a cool super
villain I decided to kill all the humans
and let the mutants rule the Earth
that's a take the Ninja Turtles kind of
get this idea that if they stop Superfly
and the mutants maybe that'll be a thing
that proves to people that they're good
and that they should be accepted it was
pretty cool to see Superfly with his
crew of mutants I'm so sorry I didn't
introduce my peace why steady Bebop hey
what you looking at bro what you looking
at Mondo Gekko peoples they got to give
Wing nuts
[Music]
Genghis frogs
don't patronize me and leather head oh I
get right fellas this idea of kind of
like bringing it to this like monster
movie type place was really fun and
exciting it's called mutant Mayhem